el vídeo de hoy ha sido posible gracias
a masterworks más sobre esto en un
momento
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el martes 26 de abril del 2022 en la
base aérea norteamericana de ramstein en
alemania se celebró una importante
cumbre más de 40 países aliados se
reunieron para comprometerse a brindar
el apoyo militar necesario para que
ucrania pueda resistir la embestida del
oso ruso tan sólo en los dos primeros
meses desde que diera comienzo la
invasión los aliados han entregado a
ucrania más de cinco mil millones de
dólares en ayuda militar nadie se deja
engañar por los pretextos de putin o por
sus falsas afirmaciones sobre el donbass
la invasión de rusia es indefendible al
igual que lo son las atrocidades rusas
las naciones de buena voluntad de todo
el mundo están unidas en la
determinación de apoyar a ucrania en su
lucha contra la agresión imperial de
rusia lloyd austin secretario de defensa
de los eeuu queridos amigos amigas más
allá de la solidaridad con ucrania la
invasión rusa ha viajado clara una cosa
no te puedes fiar de los tiranos y mucho
menos de países tan hostiles como rusia
ah
ya no cabe en paños calientes digamos
que la idea es que si se quiere la paz
hay que prepararse para la guerra esto
es un sentimiento que está creciendo a
lo largo y ancho de prácticamente todos
los países aliados del mundo desde
alemania hasta japón pasando por
australia y es exactamente lo que
explica noticias cómo está la inversión
alemana en defensa duplicará el
incremento de la deuda del país en 2022
como la guerra de ucrania está cambiando
japón tokio avanza hacia una estrategia
de seguridad más asertiva pero sobre
todo donde más está cuajando esta idea
es precisamente en los antiguos países
del pacto de varsovia si queremos evitar
lo peor es decir la guerra tenemos que
actuar de acuerdo con esa antigua regla
que dice si quieres paz prepárate para
la guerra jaroslaw kaczynski vice primer
ministro de polonia y líder del peace
prácticamente todos los países de europa
central y del este se han dado cuenta de
que tienen que empezar a prepararse para
la guerra y como decimos por aquí
y hecho eso es exactamente lo que están
haciendo y por encima de todos ellos
sobresale un país que poco a poco se
está convirtiendo en una influyente
potencia europea sabéis cuál pues antes
de que os hablamos de él dejadme que os
hable un poco de master works estarás de
acuerdo conmigo en que si algo han
demostrado los primeros meses de este
2002 y en general los últimos dos años
es que lo único seguro es que no hay
nada seguro esto también se aplica al
mundo de las finanzas para proteger el
fruto de nuestro trabajo la mayoría de
expertos suelen decir que la mejor
opción es diversificar o como se decía
antaño no poner todos los huevos en la
misma cesta recientemente en esta línea
desde jp morgan apuntaban que en este
proceso de diversificación los conocidos
como activos alternativos han dejado de
ser una simple alternativa y básicamente
han llegado para quedarse y qué mejor
ejemplo de activo alternativo que el
mercado del arte contemporáneo bueno
pues aquí es donde entra masterworks
masterworks permite a personas de
cualquier parte del mundo acceder a un
mercado hasta hace inaccesible para el
común de los mortales el arte pero es
rentable todo esto del arte
contemporáneo bueno pues este mercado
consiguió mejores datos que el propio s
p500 incluyendo dividendos apreciándose
un nada desdeñable
164 por ciento en los últimos años del
95 al 2021 bueno pues el proceso
funciona así el equipo de análisis de
máster works estudia miles de datos para
encontrar obras financieramente
atractivas con potencial de
revalorización
luego las compran por importes que van
desde el millón de dólares hasta los 30
millones y las titularizan mandando una
oferta pública a través de la secc por
último conservan la obra entre 3 y 10
años hasta que finalmente se vende si
quieres echarle un vistazo a masterworks
por ti mismo te dejamos un link con el
que te puede saltar la lista de espera y
crear una cuenta directamente sin coste
alguno ojo muy importante nadie puede
predecir el futuro y resultados pasados
no aseguran rendimientos futuros y como
siempre a la hora de invertir mucho
cuidado no existe nada libre de riesgos
[Música]
agonista destacado
cuando la unión soviética se vino abajo
a comienzos de los años 90 la nueva
ucrania independiente era uno de los
estados post comunistas más prósperos en
términos económicos prósperos en
términos dentro del contexto soviético
ya me entendéis porque lo cierto es que
todo lo que salió de la antigua unión
soviética estaba hecho un desastre aún
con todo el pib per cápita de ucrania
ajustado al nivel de precios superaba
aproximadamente en un 20 por ciento al
de polonia y amigos si esta diferencia
se hubiera mantenido hasta hoy y ucrania
hubiera logrado llevar a cabo una
transición política y económica tan
efectiva como la de polonia o la
república checa hoy la economía
ucraniana tendría casi dos tercios del
tamaño de la economía rusa claro que
como todos sabéis la historia fue muy
distinta
[Música]
las tres décadas de independencia de
ucrania han estado caracterizadas por el
estancamiento económico las divisiones
internas y una decadencia institucional
que hizo de ucrania el país más pobre de
toda europa la crisis total que la
economía ucraniana no superó su nivel de
1989 hasta el año 2005 este fue un
escenario que dio alas primero a la
invasión rusa de crimea y más tarde a la
de todo el país
sin embargo durante los últimos diez
años las cosas empezaron a cambiar en
ucrania y en que encontraron un socio
fundamental en todo este proceso estamos
hablando por supuesto de polonia
[Música]
durante la última década polonia ha sido
quizás el país que más ha influido en el
desarrollo político económico e incluso
cultural de ucrania ha sido su
partidario más firme dentro de la unión
europea y la otan acogió a más de un
millón y medio de trabajadores
ucranianos antes de la invasión y le dio
a este país el modelo para poder dar el
salto al desarrollo
[Música]
hablamos de dos países con lazos muy
estrechos entre sí de hecho durante
siglos formaron parte de la mancomunidad
polaco lituana y más recientemente
compartieron su rechazo a la ocupación
soviética no puede haber una polonia
libre sin una ucrania libre ni una
ucrania libre sino una polonia libre
refrán popular polaco pues bien ahora
tras la invasión rusa de ucrania polonia
se ha convertido en uno de los
protagonistas clave de la actualidad
política y también en el país que está
liderando la preparación europea para la
guerra atentos
una nueva potencia polaca
la invasión rusa de ucrania ha
convertido a polonia en uno de los
actores clave de la crisis el país que
está liderando junto a eeuu y reino
unido- el apoyo a ucrania la entrega de
armamento militar y la acogida de
cientos y cientos de miles millones de
refugiados tan solo en las tres primeras
semanas que siguieron a la invasión rusa
polonia acogió a más de dos millones de
refugiados para que os hagáis una idea
prácticamente de la noche a la mañana se
convirtió en el cuarto país con más
refugiados de todo el mundo tan solo por
detrás de turquía colombia y eeuu
[Música]
[Aplausos]
desde que diera comienzo la guerra el
gobierno y la sociedad polaca se han
movilizado para poner en marcha un
sistema sin precedentes alojamientos
transporte comida apoyo psicológico y
ayudas de todo tipo incluso el gobierno
polaco está pagando pequeños subsidios
mensuales a las familias que han llegado
de ucrania para que éstas puedan salir
adelante se permite a los refugiados
buscar trabajo en el país y también se
les ha abierto de par en par el sistema
sanitario y educativo decenas de miles y
miles de niños ucranianos ya están
matriculados en las escuelas polacas
hablamos de un esfuerzo titánico y eso
no es todo polonia también se ha
convertido en la puerta de entrada a
ucrania para las armas y los suministros
occidentales y en uno de los actores
políticos más relevantes del momento la
guerra de ucrania convierte a polonia en
el aliado indispensable de los eeuu
en otras palabras de repente polonia se
ha convertido en uno de los mayores
adversarios de la rusia de vladimir
putin y también en todo un ejemplo de la
carrera militar que se avecina
porque amigos polonia está en vías de
duplicar sus fuerzas armadas pasando de
unos 110 mil efectivos al entorno de los
250.000 al tiempo que también quieren
convertirse en uno de los ejércitos más
modernos de toda europa en su momento
extraordinario e histórico la
introducción de polonia en un mundo
completamente nuevo de tecnología de
vanguardia armamento moderno y medios
defensivos andrei duda presidente de
polonia porque ojo no olvidemos que
polonia tiene frontera directa tanto con
rusia a través de kaliningrado como con
bielorrusia
polonia es uno de los pocos países
europeos cuyo un presupuesto militar
supera el 2% del pib fijado como
objetivo mínimo por la otan aún así en
octubre del 2021 el vice primer ministro
polaco jaroslaw kaczynski anunció la
intención de este país de elevar aún más
su esfuerzo militar hasta alcanzar al
menos el 3% del pib
[Música]
de esta forma además de más que duplicar
el tamaño de sus fuerzas armadas el
gobierno polaco también quiere ampliar
sus fuerzas de defensa territorial un
ejército de apoyo compuesto por soldados
voluntarios y sobre todo modernizar su
arsenal militar reemplazando los
sistemas de combate que datan de la
época soviética a saber cuántos de estos
equipos terminan o mejor dicho están
terminando sus días luchando en ucrania
que mejor ocasión para hacer limpieza
nos parece por ejemplo el ejército
polaco todavía operaba unos 500 tanques
t-72 cuando dio comienzo la ofensiva
rusa y en su fuerza aérea aún
encontramos aparatos como los mig-29 y
los hubo y 22
sin embargo todo apunta a que esta
situación va a cambiar muy pronto y no
solo por los envíos de armas a ucrania
en julio del 2021 por ejemplo el
gobierno polaco anunció la compra de 250
tanques abrams estadounidenses para
complementar los 250 leopardos que
actualmente tiene su inventario otro
ejemplo lo tenemos en su envejecida
fuerza aérea durante la última década el
número de aviones de combate operativos
de polonia se redujo de 128 a 98 para
poner remedio a esta situación en 2020
el gobierno anunció un acuerdo de 4600
millones de dólares para hacerse con 32
aviones f-35 los cuales empezaron a
entregarse en 2024 ese mismo año también
adquirió por otros 4 mil 800 millones de
dólares un sistema de baterías
antiaéreas tipo patrio y más
recientemente de mayo del 21 adquirió 24
drones turcos tv2
con todo esto supone apenas una gota en
un océano para llegar a modernizar sus
fuerzas armadas polonia tendrá que hacer
un gran esfuerzo presupuestario durante
los próximos años es así el gobierno
parece más que predispuesto ojo no lo
decimos nosotros lo dice sin el más
lejos el propio vice primer ministro y
líder del partido en el gobierno
jaroslaw kaczynski fijaos
es mejor estar a salvo y un poco más
endeudados jaroslaw kaczynski vice
primer ministro de polonia pero aunque
polonia es quizás el país que más está
liderando esta especie de preparación
para la guerra en la europa oriental no
es ni mucho menos el único atentos
[Música]
y el club de la lucha'
queridos amigos amigas en la europa
centro-oriental lo tienen por lo general
muy claro no se fían ni un pelo de moscú
y si quiera formar parte de la otan lo
ven como algo suficiente así que de una
forma u otra prácticamente todos los
países de esta región están comenzando a
ponerse las pilas para seguir los pasos
de polonia un buen ejemplo lo tenemos en
la república checa- un país donde el
gasto militar no ha sido precisamente
una prioridad en los últimos años en
2022 por ejemplo apenas estaba
presupuestado gastar el 1 35 por ciento
del pib en defensa lo que en cualquier
caso suponía un importante salto desde
el 0 95 por ciento que gastaban en el
2015 sea como sea esto es algo que va a
cambiar por completo
el gobierno checo ha anunciado que tiene
la intención de incrementar un 60 por
ciento su presupuesto militar para el
2025 también bulgaria rumanía o las
repúblicas bálticas están anunciando
incrementos considerables de sus
presupuestos militares rumanía quiere
aumentar su gasto en defensa al 2,5 por
ciento del pib en esta misma línea
estonia letonia lituania van a
incrementar su gasto militar muy por
encima del 2% y teniendo claro lo harán
tomando buena nota de lo ocurrido en
ucrania por ejemplo me han puesto lo que
queráis a que los ya ver ins tendrán un
papel muy destacado
lituania gastará más de mil millones de
euros en armas de eeuu y alemania claro
que prepararse para la guerra no pasa
exclusivamente por el gasto militar ni
las relaciones políticas hay muchas más
variables que tenemos que tener en
cuenta y una de ellas muy importante son
por ejemplo las infraestructuras y
aunque puede sorprenderte este puede ser
un punto débil
para ganar una guerra o seguir una
estrategia de disuasión efectiva no solo
se necesita un ejército también tienes
que poder moverlo precisamente por eso
en 2021 se acordó el mecanismo conectar
europa un vehículo de financiación de la
unión europea que contempla
1.700 millones de dólares para mejorar
la movilidad militar sin embargo
hablamos de un presupuesto muy escaso en
un momento en que precisamente la guerra
ha dejado claro que estas cosas sí que
hacen falta así que ahora podemos decir
que la invasión rusa de ucrania está
haciendo que este asunto se convierta en
toda una prioridad preparar las
carreteras los trenes los puentes los
puertos y los aeropuertos para llegado
el caso poder mover rápidamente un
montón de tropas
[Música]
esto es algo especialmente urgente en el
caso de europa donde muchas
infraestructuras clave como son los
puentes podrían no soportar el peso de
los tanques norteamericanos británicos o
alemanes en europa aún no ha tenido la
opinión de que no necesitábamos gastar
en defensa desde el 24 de febrero cuando
rusia atacó a ucrania ese panorama ha
cambiado por completo george's rickles
analista del centro de política europea
por ejemplo uno de los proyectos que más
podría acelerarse es rail báltica una
conexión ferroviaria de ancho estándar
de 5.800 millones de euros que conecte
de forma rápida estonia letonia y
lituania con polonia una infraestructura
indispensable para garantizar que puedan
llevarse a cabo grandes movimientos de
tropas de forma rápida de hecho se habla
incluso de extender esta línea desde
estonia hasta finlandia mediante un
túnel bajo el mar pues bien pudimos
esperar que ahora este y otros proyectos
de infraestructuras cojan mucha más
velocidad así que ya lo veis las
infraestructuras son otra importante
forma de prepararse para la guerra y
mejorar la estrategia de disuasión
europea amigos amigas la historia se
empeña a repetirnos que una victoria
militar no siempre supone una victoria
geopolítica en ocasiones la guerra solo
conlleva una derrota sea lo que sea que
ocurra en el campo de batalla
la experiencia de eeuu en afganistán
irak es muy clara como también lo es la
propia experiencia de moscú con la
invasión de hungría en 1956 la invasión
de checoslovaquia en 1968 o la
imposición de la ley marcial en la
mismísima polonia en
1981 en todos estos casos el triunfo en
los campos de batalla no supuso victoria
alguna más bien todo lo contrario fueron
por así decirlo pequeños triunfos de un
país que estaba ya perdiendo la guerra
fría y que se veía incapaz de cuestionar
y fidelizar a sus países aliados del
pacto de varsovia
de hecho en todos esos casos la
intervención militar distanció
irremediablemente muchos más a los
ciudadanos húngaros checos y polacos de
rusia con independencia de lo que ocurra
en los campos de batalla de ucrania
donde rusia ya está pagando un
importante precio en términos económicos
militares y humanos el resultado de la
guerra va a ser exactamente el opuesto
al pretendido por moscú la distancia la
desconfianza y la hostilidad de los
ucranianos hacia rusia durará años sino
décadas
de todo este envite la otan que por
cierto sal haremos de ello muy pronto
aquí en visual político saldrá
fortalecida más cohesionada mejor
preparada y con la incorporación de
nuevos países si putin quería menos otan
junto a rusia ha logrado todo lo
contrario y también tendrá una frontera
con vecinos mucho más armados y
fortificados durante años rusia ha
intentado intimidar a sus antiguos
aliados del pacto de varsovia ahora no
sólo los ha envalentonado sino que en
poco tiempo estarán en disposición de
mirar de tú a tú a la mismísima rusia y
para colmo está convirtiendo a polonia
en toda una potencia continental
[Música]
lo miremos por donde lo miremos rusia ha
perdido esta guerra claro que eso ya lo
sabíamos si tuviéramos que repartir un
premio a la idea política más absurda
descabellada y contraproducente por lo
menos la última década sería difícil
encontrar un candidato mejor que putin
con su atroz invasión de ucrania pero
amigos llegamos hasta aquí turno para ti
como ves los planes de los países de la
europa oriental crees que polonia
finalmente se consolidará como toda una
potencia europea deberían el resto de
países de europa a secundar estos
esfuerzos déjanos por aquí abajo tus
comentarios y ahora si este vídeo os
resulta interesante no olvidéis darle al
botón de like i suscribiros a visual
política si es que aún no lo habéis
hecho un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]